everyone I knew I felt like had the most
wonderful experience after they had
their baby but I didn't know how to say
like I am freaking out postpartum
depression to me is the disconnect you
have with your baby an overwhelming
uncontrollable sense of anxiety one of
many mental illnesses that can affect
mothers when I got pregnant I was
instantly in a bad mood in addition to
that I had fibroids which are tumors
that grow in your uterus and it was
really scary I knew I had postpartum
depression for the first time when I
went to go and pump my breast milk at
work and I just broke down crying I
actually remember saying to my husband
you know people kept saying I'd be so
emotional and I feel fine and the
reality of the situation was that I was
completely emotionally numb right after
I had the baby it was my husband's
birthday so I baked him a cake and I
invited people over and people were like
what are you doing but I felt like it
was my duty to celebrate his birthday to
try to nurse and then come back and put
on a happy face
I believed that every parent around me
knew what they were doing and that I was
this devastating failure when my son was
four months old and I remember
breastfeeding him but he wouldn't stop
crying and I got face to face with him
and I screamed stop crying
that was probably the moment I realized
I needed help it's a really defeating
feeling knowing that this is something
you have no control over I thought after
that moment I just need to hold my baby
I don't ever want this to happen again
and something has to change being a
stay-at-home mom was really isolating
but I felt like I kind of came out of it
when I started exercising and hanging
out with other moms I started feeling
better when I could wake up to my baby
every morning and he just makes
everything better and every
while to all the mothers going through
this surround yourself with people who
get it because you're not alone I know
there's so much pressure right now to be
like a perfect mom you have to be honest
you have to let people in and let them
know what you're going through if you
are out there and you are struggling I
want you to know that it is going to get
better I'm a mother and I am vulnerable
that I am capable and I am fighting
every day and I'm doing the best that I
can and struggling with postpartum
depression didn't make me weak but
becoming victorious over it that's what
made me strong
we have lost way too many moms so please
stay with us find yourself a community
and keep fighting
Oh